your second single dokoko is sexy man
it's for that person that you have very
um you know special in your life and you
want to dedicate that song to is that
special person still in your life
i haven't seen you since you've gone
solo since you changed your name but i
love it because de leon is actually a
tribute to your grandpa right exactly
yeah you know um
it's been really nice being able to do
this change uh especially the the last
name change from the deleon dylan's my
last name that that has you know the
music running through the veins so it's
really nice to be able to you know live
with that now do you feel like you've
started to step into a more authentic
side of yourself in your music
definitely i obviously enjoyed
everything i was doing in the band but i
felt like each person in the band had
like their own role so then to some
extent it kind of felt like we were kind
of limited so you know i took this risk
of doing my own thing and i feel like
completely free i feel very happy
[Applause]
[Music]
talk to me about the first thing
because i was also inspired by your
grandpa too right yes i don't know where
this idea came to my to my head of doing
something that of the genre that my my
grandpa would be singing as a kid when i
was a kid so then um
one of the producers brought out the
guitar he strummed the first chord and
he just you know it was born from there
it was very authentic you know it was
very natural it happened like in an hour
and a half so you know after doing that
like i realized that i can do that type
of music as well so i love it it's been
cool well look at this single artwork
right here what would your grandpa say
about you and like in a vaquero no he
would love it um i remember as a kid i
would also dress as a mariachi so you
know he would really love it i think
he'd be really proud of what i'm doing
right now um your second single coco is
sexy man
[Music]
it is such a good song talk to me about
the inspiration behind the track were
you thinking of someone in particular
when you were writing that so yeah
actually yeah um
it's crazy because
i'm talking about a um like a like a
heartbreak type of story and then with
goku it's talking about love it's an
ideology and a soulmate so yeah it's for
that song that you know that i mean it's
for that person that you have very um
you know special in your life and you
want to dedicate that song too is that
special person still in your life yeah
yeah okay
so you know
i was gonna ask you what you're looking
for in a soul mate but it sounds like
you might already found it there yeah
i'm trying to take notes all right
what's the secret
i don't know i think she's gotta be very
very genuine on gotta connect and that's
basically it you know i don't really
look for too much stuff as long as
they're as long as there's chemistry and
that great connection but how do you do
that in this industry i mean especially
now when you're really starting to carve
this path for yourself right like how do
you have the time um you know we both
live in miami i'm most of the time when
i'm out creating music yeah when i'm
creating music i'm usually out there so
you know i spend a lot of time out there
i i live there it's my base so you know
there's a balance there you go well you
had an explosion of creativity during
the pandemic what was that the catalyst
for you to go solo you know now that you
get to kind of do your own thing
it was definitely um one of the biggest
reasons of of why i took the decision um
i feel like there were so many ideas
that came into my mind that i couldn't i
couldn't hold them in anymore i felt
like i felt kind of like closed in like
there there was some type of angus
it was not you know i was uh you know i
took the risk um at first the guys were
shocked in shock for a bit um but they
eventually realized it was you know
eventually gonna happen like an almost
all boy benson right and the thing is
though when uh i feel like members leave
and exit these groups you know sometimes
there's because of drama or there's a
rivalry but that's not the case with you
guys oh right not at all it was actually
kind of a beautiful ending that last
show yeah it was emotional yeah oh my
gosh i just remembered that yeah it's
about to be a year oh actually crazy but
um like you say we're we're in good
terms we actually just saw each other um
like a week ago at vegas for an award
show and we spend time there so
everything's good we're gonna keep on
being boys forever so how does it feel
to know that you still have their
support in this journey because it's not
that's not always the case yeah i know
but um i do have the support they have
my support um we were talking like with
i was talking with them individually
with all men they're really happy too
you know they're supporting me they're
saying they like what i'm doing and all
that type of stuff so it really does
make me feel happy um to know that
they're still there for me and the fans
i mean the fans are still riding with
you too do you feel that yeah no i
definitely do at first i was a little
bit scared because i was going to change
there was a whole bunch of changes you
know from the first genre which was like
which no one has ever heard in my voice
um to my last name that changed so you
know it was a risk but everyone kind of
rode along we've been experimenting with
other genres so what can you tease about
what we can expect from maybe your full
debut record like what direction are you
heading
oh wow um this last year i've been
honestly experimenting a whole bunch of
different things but always being honest
with with who i am i'm not trying to
stick to the trends just because it's
trending yeah but um you guys are going
to be able to hear a whole bunch of new
things that you haven't heard like for
example like pop rock on my voice r b
um house
um a lot a bit more of pop there's a lot
of cool things in there in store i don't
really want to reveal everything because
you know i want i want to make it a
surprise what have the studio sessions
been like like what's the vibe the
studio scenes have been really really
great i feel like i've learned so much
yeah this last year i've learned a lot
about myself musically and and you know
it's super cool i felt i mean i felt
even way more passionate you know this
last year being super focused on what my
my um you know what my career is as a
solo artist and and yeah i just feel i
have a really big drive to get things
done do you feel the pressure to get
those things done or do you feel like
you get to actually have more creative
freedom and you can just try things and
also take your time to figure out what
this is gonna all sound like together so
at first i did kind of have like i kind
of felt like i had a pressure to like to
impress and all that stuff but but
eventually i you know when i kept going
to the studio and kept making music it
was making me really happy with what the
outcome was so it's kind of it's kind of
just that you know as long as it's
making me happy and seeing that the
people are liking it as of now that's
what's really motivating you get to just
vibe exactly i love it i love it well
i'm thinking like if coco was about
finding your soul mate i think the next
song needs to be about thirst traps
because bro
you are giving it to us even you're
using your dog as a prop too exactly no
you know what
to give like a little exclusive there
actually is some kind of like you know
there's trap and in a way you know
sometimes some some lines aren't pokemon
so okay so it's just all part of the
message it's all part of it
i love it congratulations thank you for
hanging with us today uh we're actually
gonna let joelle deleon play us out as
we say goodbye here's his latest single
coco we'll see you guys next time on
et's
[Music]
god